welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka willy wonka in this
video we're breaking down the ending of
2021's candyman candyman is a film that
scared the crap out of me as a kid and
though i didn't appreciate the social
commentary at the time it's been
something that i've constantly gone back
to over the years it's certainly a movie
that has stood the test of time and it's
one of the standouts of the decade in
this video we'll be going over the new
film's plot and also giving our
interpretation of it and because of this
there will be heavy spoilers eh now if
you enjoy the video then please smash
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this each
and every day without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
candyman
okay so candyman is based on clive
barker's short story the forbidden
candyman spawned a massive franchise and
this has led to a new film by nier de
costa and jordan peele a book by barker
actually appears at one point in the
movie and it's nice that they gave a nod
to the source material even if the story
is pretty changed up from it now how we
got to this point is quite an
interesting one and just in case you
need a quick catch up on the first film
i thought i'd give a run down just to
jog everyone's memories time codes will
be linked below if you want to skip
ahead but i'll try and keep this short
and sweet now we began in chicago with
helen lyle who learned about the
candyman legend when researching the
cabrini green housing project in the
movie we discovered that candyman was
born in the 1800s and he became a famous
artist he was hired by several wealthy
white families and he ended up falling
in love with the daughter of one of
these after she fell pregnant her father
sent a mob after him and they cut off
his hand and poured honey over him in
order to attract bees they brutally
stung his body and in front of a crowd
the mob set him a light his ashes were
then scattered across where cabrini
green would be created helen discovered
that if he said the name candyman into a
mirror five times that his vengeful
spirit would appear and murder you canny
man's powers can very much be taken away
depending on whether people talk about
him or not and this is a theme that
plays heavily into the movie initially
he was thought to be a legend used to
cope with the pain that had been
inflicted on black people by whites but
helen quickly discovered that there was
more to it than that after coming across
a resident there named anne marie and
her son anthony candyman ended up
framing helen for the kidnapping of the
ladder and she was locked up in an
asylum helen managed to escape with
candyman's help and she returned to
cabrini green to save the child canny
man told her that if she joined him that
he'd spare the child but he backtracked
on this deal and he attempted to kill
the baby in a giant fire helen ended up
sacrificing herself to save him though
she did end up becoming a similar sort
of vengeful spirit which sort of ties
into this brand new movie now an adult
anthony becomes the protagonist of the
piece and when we join him he's a
struggling artist trying to get his name
out there much in the same way that he
wishes to gain notoriety of his name
candyman wants the same thing and slowly
the two paths become aligned after
hearing of helen's story he takes a trip
out to cabrini green which is slowly
going through the process of
gentrification here he meets william
burke who we learn is trying to start a
new candyman legend in order to get
revenge on those that have caused his
people so much pain now i don't want to
be a white english guy telling black
americans what a film like this is
actually about so i'm more than happy
for people to correct me and say whether
they had a different interpretation or
not in the film we see candyman more as
a mantle instead of a single entity and
because of this i took the metaphor very
much to be a representation of
generational pain as burke says candyman
ain't a he he's the whole damn hive and
we meet several versions of the
character towards the end of the film it
turns out that cabrini green has been
the site of several racially motivated
crimes from white people against the
black community and this constant
feeling of anguish has caused a literal
tear in the fabric of the location so
that several vengeful spirits exist
there now again this is very much how i
took the film but the spirits of the
quote unquote candy men very much
represent generational trauma often
described by experts as being something
that manifests within communities we
witness how the idea of pain is passed
from generation to generation the elders
of the community all have their own
candyman stories which they then tell
the younger people about who then end up
seeing their own legends created before
their eyes which end up being inherited
by the future as well generational
trauma still has very little known about
it but research states that these
stories can often lead to anxieties
within a community that are further
fueled by their experiences there's a
reason that some people get nervous when
they see the police and according to the
studies even if they haven't had a bad
encounter with them before it can still
lead to a certain perception being
formed the website has carried out
several studies and it notes that the
condition isn't just exclusive to the
black community and it's also popped up
in the children of sexual assault
survivors and the grandchildren of those
that experience the holocaust i'm
veering off into a lot of outward
territory around the film but it does
explain why there's this idea of a
candyman that isn't just one person but
rather a collective throughout the movie
anthony becomes obsessed with this and
after he returns to cabrini green he's
stung by a bee that slowly disfigures
his arm it's at this location that we
discover that the character sherman
fields became the latest version of the
candyman and this idea of the torch
being passed does become dramatic in the
film fields gave out candy to children
but when a white girl had one with a
razor blade inside the police ended up
tracking him down and they murdered him
his face was beaten beyond recognition
and it's likely that a lot of the
legends in the film actually pull from
real life cases such as emmett till till
was said to have flirted and whistled at
a white woman and a mob brutally
murdered him his face was so disfigured
that he couldn't even be recognized but
his mother bravely held an open casket
funeral so that the world could see what
had happened to her son tail never
actually whistled at anyone and similar
to him fields was an innocent man the
movie very much puts across the idea
that the police have a shoot first ask
questions like a mentality and it's
clear that some people canny man even
seems like a protection their presence
looms over the film quite a lot and even
in the opening scene we see how they
rule over cabrini green and are judge
jurian executioner the film culminates
with anthony being wrongly killed by the
police and thus he becomes the next
candyman now we'll talk about this later
on in the video but throughout the film
we watch his anthony becomes more and
more obsessed with the legend of the
candyman and after his work around it
becomes a murder site the stories of how
to summon the villains start to grow and
grow to me the movie very much
represents the anger of the oppressed
who wish to find ways to fight back
through using their voice candyman's
arrival is very much summoned by saying
his name and in doing so you give the
legend attention this then brings light
to the horrible crimes that were
committed on those who ended up becoming
the vengeful spirits and it's important
that they aren't overlooked because of
what happened to them we learned that
burke was the person who caused fields
to get caught and after his sister was
killed by summoning the spirit he became
obsessed with him too due to
gentrification white people have
basically ousted all the black people
that live in cabrini and burke wants the
misery that his community has faced
through candyman to affect them too he
wishes to start up a new legend with
anthony at the center of it and he
kidnaps him along with his girlfriend
brianna burke cuts off anthony's arm
jams a hook into it and calls the police
knowing that the murders will be pinned
on him brianna manages to escape and
bert catches up to her but she fights
back and stabs him to death at this
point anthony arrives but so do the
police and they end up shooting and
killing him even though he wasn't posing
a threat brianna is taken in by a
policeman and he threatens her and says
that she has to tell people that anthony
attacked them and that they had to shoot
him in self-defense instead she summons
anthony who arrives and kills all the
police there fully becoming a new legend
that has just started his own myth and
then he ends up catching up to the final
police officer and this is where he
fully becomes a new iteration of
candyman as we watch his face more
through all the iterations of those that
were brutally murdered at the site he
chases after the final policeman and
kills him before his face morphs into
the tony todd version of the character
aka daniel daniel tells brianna to tell
everyone what's happened and thus the
legend will continue to grow and expand
now that's the main ending for the film
though we do get some more of the shadow
puppet sequences which explain the
stories that have come before and what
will happen going forward throughout the
movie we see several versions of the
canny man tale and the first one tells
the story of daniel and how he was
murdered the second one told of a man
that argued he was being ripped off and
because of this he was killed the third
was a story of a young boy who was given
the electric chair after a girl said he
assaulted her this too is similar to
till and we of course get shermanfield's
story before we see anthony joining them
the movie ends with the five legends all
standing together as they're joined by
several more shadows invoking the idea
of the voiceless victims uniting as one
in order to wreak havoc on those that
overlooked and didn't believe in them
only the arrogant that disregard the
legend of candyman end up falling victim
to him i think it's a really smart idea
to portray in this way it's such a good
metaphor and like most of the other
critics i really enjoyed the movie i
think if you view it on a surface
leveler it might not really work as a
straight up slasher but there's a lot of
important social commentary here that is
definitely worth discussing there are
some standout moments and it probably
will be something that sticks with me
for a long time peel has always been
great at dressing up deeply layered
films as horrors and nier de costa will
definitely be a director to look out for
in the future she's currently working on
the marvels and i'm very excited to see
what comes from that now the
cinematography here atmosphere and
performances really elevate it i found
it enjoyable even if there were some
bits here and there that i think could
have been cut just to hurry things along
that being said uh i did take a lot away
from candyman and i hope you've had fun
with the breakdown too this was a movie
i think you should definitely watch and
overall it gets an 8.5 out of 10. now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know we're running a competition
right now and giving away three mcu
boxes on the 30th of august and all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want something
else to watch we've just done a big
breakdown on the perfect scene in
spiderman homecoming which i would be
very happy if you went and watched it's
something that i wanted to talk about
for a while and we sort of discussed the
the character points in it and also
why it just explains why spider-man is
spider-man if not then thank you for
sitting through the video i've been paul
and i'll see you next time take care
peace